new at 11 the Public Utilities
Commission approving a plan for NV
Energy to build a new gas-powered plant
at the site of the Silver Hawk
Generating Station near Apex that plant
would supplement the solar-powered grid
already in place if that grid reaches
its peak meaning it would only be used
if necessary and the energy sending a
statement in the plan which says in part
this decision ensures that NV Energy can
provide reliable energy for nevadans
especially during the state's hottest
month even with the construction of the
Silver Hawk peaking plant and the energy
will still help the state meet its
renewable portfolio standard as well as
carbon goals